I'm gonna be honest with you guys I've
been putting this video off for almost a
year now revisiting the worst of Game of
Thrones is always a painful experience
to go through and after making my almost
half hour long breakdown of season 8 I
was broken and drained and did not want
to go back to talking about these
episodes but this video is inevitable if
I made a top 10 best episodes video then
I have to do the flip side so get ready
to Feast on my misery as we dive into
the worst episodes of Game of Thrones
number 10 season 6 episode 1 the red
woman this might be a bit surprising to
some people that season 6 is leaking
onto this list but after revisiting this
episode during my season six Devore to
logic videos Ari lived how bad this
episode was almost every scene here has
a glaring writing issue that doesn't
make any sense from the whole situation
with sir Alistar allowing someone to
take John's body and then getting mad
about it along with him openly admitting
that he killed Jon Sansa and Theon
conveniently getting saved by Brienne
and when she was busy with Stannis the
power grab in Dorne is extremely
inconsistent since ellaria's sand was
literally just attained by guards for a
potential coup and now they're A-Okay
with killing Doran the sand snakes being
on the ship with Jaime mercel and
Tristan and for some reason they let
Jaime go despite them killing Tristan
the sons of the harpy being able to burn
dany's entire fleet without anyone
noticing the Dothraki going out of their
way to capture Dany when they didn't
know who she was Jesus Christ the
writing tanks so hard in this episode
and I'm surprised that we were so blind
to this when it first came out like
there's really nothing to be enjoyed
here even the dialogue is at an all-time
low I was considering putting an episode
from the beginning of season 7 here but
at least there's a scene or two that are
at least entertaining within those
episodes then the red woman ends in the
most scarringly disgusting way possible
in which Melisandre takes off her
necklace and we see her shriveled up
ball sack of a corpse did we really need
to see this not to mention that this is
all also inconsistent with past scenes
in which she didn't have her necklace on
she didn't turn into the old lady from
SpongeBob this is a prime early example
of David and Dan struggling to write an
episode from scratch Number Nine Season
5 episode 6 unbowed unbent unbroken
despite the terrible scenes that
transpire within this episode that we'll
talk about in the second 25 of this
episode is made up of Thoroughly
engaging scenes of Arya doing chores
this is a point where I'm sure this
whole development is way better in the
books because you could have arya's
internal monologue and extensive thought
process while in the house of black and
white but in the show you obviously
can't do that and she doesn't have
another character for her to talk to and
express what she's thinking that's why
to me this whole development with her
here is so boring along with Jack and
seemingly jumping the gun and
immediately showing Arya the Great Hall
with all the faces even though she is
still failing her tests so that's a big
chunk of the episode that most people
will probably skip all all together the
crazy thing is that the episode gets
progressively worse as it goes on like
we then go to Tyrion and Sergio getting
captured by Pirates and they consider
chopping off tyrion's [ __ ] which is just
such a jarringly weird dialogue scene
and when you compare this to tearing out
smarting the mountain tribe is such a
massive difference in quality in one
scene you have Tyrion taking advantage
of the low IQ of his captors and
promising them riches along with
defusing all the tension with his
well-executed humor in the other Tyrion
just says that he has a big [ __ ] so yeah
and also do [ __ ] Merchants even exist
then Littlefinger scheming is baffling
and has no semblance of coherency since
he gave Sansa to the boltons and now he
wants to become Warden of the north by
attacking the boltons and a part of this
plan between him and Cersei is he'll
kill Sansa so right away the scene is
pointless because we know that won't
happen Dave and Dan were just like oh we
have a bare minimum requirement to make
it seem as if Littlefinger is still
smart and is scheming the episode keeps
spy trailing with a terrible climax of
The Dorm plot line and any action here
is poorly executed with tons of cutting
it also doesn't make sense how these
soldiers choose not to turn when they do
so a few episodes later in season six
how convenient for Jaime who's
infiltrating Dorne the final scene of
the episode is probably one of the most
abhorrent moments in the show in which
Ramsay rapes Sansa we really didn't need
to see this and felt more like David and
Dan injecting Shock Valley to try and
increase ratings number eight season 7
episode 5 East watch oh boy I love
opening an episode by getting smacked in
the face with a big schlanga plot armor
Braun must be an Olympic free diver if
he was able to swim Jaime while he was
in full armor across an entire Lake it's
very clear that David and Dan wrote
themselves into a corner by including
Jamie Braun in this battle and needed
some way for them to escape and they
didn't even try to make it make sense
and then dickon randomly just kills
himself and I feel like Dave and dammer
probably think thinking I don't know
what to do with this character let's
just kill him screw it and then they try
to play this off as Daenerys being
unreasonable like okay one of the main
reasons why I'm including this episode
within my list is because of how
absurdly fast each character was able to
travel around Westeros just in this
episode alone we go from this general
area to Dragonstone from Dragonstone to
King's Landing from King's Landing back
to Dragonstone and then from Dragonstone
all the way to the goddamn wall this
destroys any semblance of space within
this world because it destroys all logic
and how long it would take to travel to
these locations the main way to make it
seem natural would be to have in between
scenes or even episodes to pad up that
time but David and Dan gave up and
cranked up the pace it's also funny to
me how Dany returns to Dragonstone on
drogon but somehow the Dothraki made it
back before her because these people
were present during the Lutheran attack
the other big reason why this episode is
here is because of tyrion's brilliant
plan to kidnap a white to convince
Cersei to help them I don't think I need
to dive into why this mashed potatoes
logic is coming out of young Sheldon
because obviously it would get everyone
killed and Cersei would gladly Let the
dead kill the north because that would
be her best chances of winning at this
point from this point on it's basically
as if the dragon crew is assembling The
Avengers as they zip around the globe
and it's even served up with Marvel
quips like Davos quoting the meme of
Gendry endlessly rowing thought you
might still be rolling before this
season 7 was mediocre and was kind of
bad but this episode self-mutilated the
potential of any Redemption for the rest
of the season from how horrendous the
direction David and Dan decided to take
the story here while also fully and
utterly compromising Tyrion who was once
my favorite character number seven
season eight episode one Winterfell this
episode doesn't have a lot of
atrociously insulting scenes that make
you want to light Your Eyes on Fire and
then extinguish them in acid but the
general writing is still coded in trash
and is apparent by this point that David
and Dan stop trying hell the first line
of the season is Tyrion making a [ __ ]
joke seems that you'd think should have
nothing wrong with them sore being
fumbled Ari and Jon's reunion is
laughably short and lazily written
King's Landing is completely Barren and
since it's just Cersei and euron Dave
and Dan have no idea what they should
talk about other than sex and elephants
oddly Braun is given an objective to
kill Tyran and Jaime despite Cersei not
actually wanting that so it puts his
character in limbo the whole season as
he goes to the Bahamas for a vacation
Dion just waltzes into euron's Fleet
with zero conflict and saves Yara
rendering that whole plot Point as
anticlimactic Jon and Daenerys Riding
Dragons is shockingly reduces sitcom
satire when it should have been a
triumphant reveal and tormund and Ed
conveniently run into each other despite
it being illogical it feels like anyone
could have reviewed this script and
addressed these issues but the only
thing I can think of is Dave and Dan not
caring even some of the biggest moments
feel dampened by the poor dialogue
during the Grand reveal of Jon Snow
being aegon Targaryen he just resorts to
the copy and pasted dialogue that it
repeats for the entire season not to
mention that the scene ends in less than
a minute after Sam tells Jon the big
news if David and Dan Ryan rushing
through these scenes as fast as possible
then they could have easily written 10
episodes worth this is kind of a larger
issue within season 7 and 8 but it's
more noticeable for the episodes that
are primarily composed of dialogue
scenes how am I supposed to form any
attachment to these scenes when you're
quickly ending them with very little
resolution and proper development it
feels like we're just going down a
checklist of plot points to set up
before getting to the big action set
pieces instead of having any semblance
of being like the earlier Seasons where
each dialogue scene was fully explored
and engaged the audience with its
riveting and complex characters just
thinking about the notion of Sansa and
Jon having a scene together arguing
makes me sick to my stomach at this
point in the story number six season
seven episode seven the dragon and the
Wolf the last 20 minutes of this episode
ranges from all rate to good but the
first hour is an absolutely miserable
experience we have a 40-minute sequence
of our now brain dead characters trying
to have an intellectual discussion
starting off this 40 minute long
nightmare we have Brawn talking about
unsullied who don't have [ __ ] ah yes I
sure do love the topics that David and
den decide to explore in their dialogue
scenes then for the actual General
reunion it never has any substance from
the blatantly game Bull and skippable AD
euron randomly chiming in to make jokes
and Jon giving his night King speech for
the 100th time this is just terrible for
the amount of characters here it's
really sad that Dave and Dan weren't
able to come up with a single memorable
or even decent interaction this also
isn't even mentioning how this entire
sequence has no point in the overall
story why is Cersei even entertaining
the notion that she cares about helping
what are Jon and Danny going to do about
her not helping kill her her harder like
what's the point of Cersei bamboozling
everyone here that she's going to help
it literally serves no purpose and it
just wastes time if you were to remove
this scene and went right into season 8
almost nothing changes the only key
difference is Jaime's involvement but he
can so easily write it away for him to
get upset and to help the living if
anything I'd prefer an arc where Jaime
realizes how evil Cersei is and that
aspect slowly drives him away and he
switches sides not because she lied
given that Jaime's overall Arc is
basically the opposite of cersei's and
that he's becoming more honorable and
morally good while cersei's becoming
more wicked and is pushed further into
that Abyss through each death of her
kids you think that the death of tommen
would have a bigger impact within their
relationship because Cersei was
partially responsible but that whole
aspect was unexplored or even just
acknowledging the fact that she blew up
the set the King's Landing narrative in
the season was so Bare Bones already
that this more developed dynamic between
Cersei and Jaime was much needed
although Jaime's Arc works here in this
episode I think it could have been done
better so taking out the factor of Jaime
it feels like this entire sequence is
only to justify the reunion of Cersei
and Tyrion so that Dave and Dan can try
and utterly fail at reliving the best of
game of thrones's past and the sad thing
is that it worked the critics ate that
[ __ ] up and the season received a bunch
of awards then there's one other
crippling issue in this episode and
that's the death of Littlefinger saying
that Dave and Dent committed a character
assassination would be kind because this
man has been done so dirty since the
beginning of season five the more you
think about anything Littlefinger does
the less it makes sense and then to make
things even worse bran just farts around
and doesn't bother with telling anyone
that littlefingers and Menace to Society
David and Dan yet again create a false
sense of tension because it's completely
illogical for bran to withhold this
critical information this finale is a
massive waste of time and it also comes
with a side of David and Dan plunging a
dagger into our hearts for how they
handled a beloved character her number
five season seven episode six Beyond the
Wall this was the original point in the
show that shattered my illusion That
Game of Thrones was still a good show
because before this the flaws were there
but they were somewhat ignorable because
they didn't go absolutely ape [ __ ] in
terms of terrible writing the inherent
goal that Dave and Dan created where
John and Company have to go beyond the
wall to steal white is single-handedly
one of the most stupid directions to
take the story I still don't know why
they couldn't have Dany at least fly
them in and out for this Mission instead
of what transpired or even Dany flying
in to scoop up some whites and drogon's
Claws and bringing them back south the
fact that you can immediately with very
little thought come up with a better
plan than the smartest character in the
show is very telling for how horrendous
the whole episode is then the execution
of the episode writing wise is even
worse the whites that end up chasing
Jon's Entourage end up getting stopped
because the Ice broke even though they
have been shown to be able to swim
Gendry a man who grew up in the warm
climate of King's Landing is able to
somehow run miles non-stop back to the
wall without his lungs exploding in this
extremely cold weather you'd think that
tormund would be more suited for that
objective given that he grew up in this
terrain Jon's Entourage constantly
surviving certain death scenarios Jon
for whatever reason not wanting to get
on drogon because he was getting carried
away killing whites and then Jon
miraculously surviving and having Uncle
Benjamin come in like the Eagles from
The Lord of the Rings to save him did we
need to have this moment for Uncle
benjen then this is padded out with a
dumb conflict of if Arya is going to
kill Sansa and Sansa is again listening
to Littlefinger someone who she really
should not be trusting at this point
almost every aspect of this episode
sucks ass and there may be a few moments
in the beginning with some interesting
dialogue but it's jarring to constantly
use [ __ ] jokes in almost every episode
number 4 season 8 episode 4 the last of
the Starks oh boy here we go between the
last four episodes of season 8 I hate
this one the least because it doesn't
absolutely butcher a major aspect that
the show has been building towards but
don't get me wrong the last of the
Starks is still horrible this episode
includes the single most jarring point
in the entire show which is the death of
rhaegal the fact that Dave and Dan
played this seem to surprise the
audience as random shock value is the
most degenerate form of writing a good
twist should be logical within the story
at the very least it should have a small
threat of build up like the right
wedding and the death of Ned Stark here
it feels like Dave and Dan are in panic
mode as they have no idea how to match
those highs from the earlier Seasons
what's that we were literally just
reminded about euron's Fleet the scene
prior oh shouldn't we send scouting
ships ahead so that we stop getting
ambushed by euron's Fleet which already
happened twice in the story you'd think
that they would learn from their
mistakes but David and Dan throughout
all logic and the story to bend and
break it at their own will this time to
the complete detriment of one of dany's
dragons that the audience has come to
love through the years and this is just
one scene in the episode the vast
majority of the celebration plays like a
sitcom because Dave and Dan find it
easier to write quote unquote comedy
rather than drama along with it
including this classic line I don't
really want anymore which perfectly sets
up the ending in which he wants to
become the king why do you think I came
all this way the romance between Jamie
and bran felt really awkward to me John
is stuck in his never-ending Loop of
saying McQueen and I don't want it Braun
randomly comes in out of nowhere to then
exit the story again and missande
somehow gets captured by euron with a
dash of coughing Varys I am leaving out
one scene that upsets me more than these
which is Jon telling Arya and Sansa his
true identity this again highlights
Steven and Dan's utter laziness in
writing because they don't even bother
to show us critical reactions of his
closest family members like this should
be the best scene of the episode and
David and Dan somehow fumble the easiest
touchdown in existence then the final
scene is so bizarre where Daniel his
support group shows up to cersei's
doorstep to beg them to surrender this
essentially resembles the finale of
season 7 where everyone knows the
outcome of the scene and it ends up
being pointless but the reason why this
moment is worse is because Cersei has
the means to end the war right now she
has multiple scorpions pointing out a
motionless drogon and could easily
barrage dany's whole group with arrows
or they could literally just open the
gates to reveal the golden company that
then Slaughters them Cersei doesn't have
Jaime's good moral conscious to hold her
back and I'm surprised John didn't
encourage her to slaughter them all here
but yet again this is another contrived
scenario so Tyrion could give an
emmy-baiting monologue to Cersei number
three season 8 episode 3 The long nights
if I were to go back and remake my
devoted logic videos for season 8 I'd
find the most material within this
episode from how crazily brainless it
all is so let's go through a quick
laundry list of everything I can think
of that's stupid in this episode John
and Danny waiting an unnecessarily long
time to do strafe runs on the army of
the Dead the Dothraki randomly charging
the enemy despite being told not to the
layout of the army by having the
trebuchets in the front of your soldiers
and not digging more trenches our
Frontline Heroes miraculously surviving
a literal wave of Undead that washed
over them Our non-fighting Heroes hiding
in the Crypt that famously has corpses
in them not creating a Fail-Safe
mechanic to light the trench on fire if
a dragon becomes incapacitated not
having any siege-like materials like
pouring oil in the dead and John being
able to keep fighting after crashing on
rhaegal and being A-Okay along with
being surrounded by whites and surviving
also not to exaggerate but almost every
instance in which our characters are
fighting the undead they are put into
scenarios where they should have died I
think everyone was surrounded at some
point and the whites decided to hug them
instead of instantly stabbing them like
they did to the extras let alone Sam the
Slayer wrestling the undead in the mud
you can't go a few minutes in the long
night without being visually assaulted
by the abysmal writing and having plot
armor permeate in every single moment
what a great way to destroy any form of
tension when everyone is Immortal now
then that isn't even bringing into light
or should I say Darkness the fact that
you can't see anything I get that this
battle takes place at night but any
example of night shoots for battles has
tangible Lighting in them and you can
always use the moon as a general light
source also despite this entire episode
being an action set piece there was only
a couple choreographed extended fight
scenes like Arya fighting up on the wall
besides that all the action is just
quick shots of people randomly swinging
at whites and that quickly gets
repetitive so since we covered all that
shite we can now finally talk about the
ending the fact that Dave and Dan are
basing the entirety of this moment on
subverting expectations instead of a
proper moment of payoff that has been
built up to for years is mind-boggling
it's very clear that David and Dan
didn't know what to do with Arya later
on in the season so they probably
panicked and gave her the night King
even though her killing the night King
doesn't actually utilize any of the
skills she acquired because she
literally just rushes in for the kill or
fly I should say this episode manages to
completely squander the single biggest
aspect of the show that so many people
were hyped to see and it was the major
moment where the casuals realized how
bad the show was because up until this
point the show is still getting good
reviews on IMDb number 2 Season 8
Episode 5 the bells this episode is like
having the foresight that a train is
about to crash and you are powerless to
stop it and you have to witness it in
slow motion I'm sure this episode
wouldn't be absolutely terrible if David
and Dan bother to do some real writing
and develop these characters and have
them make realistic decisions based in
logic with real Seasons composed of 10
episodes that don't just rush through
the plot points in an any percent speed
run then I'm sure this moment in the
story would make sense but the fact that
Dany wins the war with essentially no
losses and then decides to snap for no
good reason is baffling it creates an
immediate disconnect with her character
because the writers are forcing her to
do something that isn't properly set up
and are only filling in a plot point
that George R Martin told them that
happens then we are left to sit here and
witness this [ __ ] for the remainder of
the episode it's really hard to enjoy
this spectacle when it doesn't feel
earned in any way that's why I can't
give it any redeeming qualities not to
mention that there are still dumb
aspects like the Scorpion suddenly not
working like in every wide shot that
shows the Scorpions there are always
motionless and they seem like they
aren't manned which is a massive
difference from the episode before that
had Regal get headshotted from miles
away while moving and of course all this
is accompanied by other disgustingly
incompetent writing choices like Jaime
saying he doesn't care for the Innocence
which broke his character Arc euron
coincidentally swimming to shore at the
exact spot in time Jaime is there Arya
suddenly transforming into a cat because
she now has nine lives and Jamie and
Cersei dying to a bunch of bricks when
literally any other fan theory that
predicts the fate of Cersei and Jaime is
better than what you were able to come
up with then he know that you're
horrible writers every now and then
you'd find maybe one of these egregious
writing mistakes in the last couple of
seasons like Arya getting stabbed
multiple times and living in season six
but here writing mistakes of that
caliber happen in every other scene the
only thing here that is half
entertaining is Clegane Bowl but even
that feels like fan service in a way I
feel really bad for the actual
production side of things because it's a
complete waste of talent and having all
these amazing effects and huge sets
bring to life in atrocious script number
one season eight episode six the Iron
Throne by this point in season 8 I was
inconsolable I sat there like a lifeless
husk as I witnessed my favorite show
succumbed to some of the worst writing
I've ever witnessed so does it get
better from here
absolutely [ __ ] not not only does
this episode have a plethora of
god-awful moments it's also overly drawn
out with filler we have to watch every
character slowly walk through King's
Landing as if this is some deeply moving
material interion moves chairs around
like an ADHD Maniac Dave and Dan are in
full crisis mode as HBO in the audience
expects them to Output episodes over an
hour long so they just give you drool
inducing scenes that don't engage the
audience in any way like what was the
point of this scene where greyworm was
executing soldiers and clearly was so
far gone that he didn't care anymore
shouldn't this be setting up a showdown
of sorts between gray worm and Jon after
Jon kills Dany since greyworm clearly
wouldn't let Jon live after doing that
it seems like this scene was on The
Cutting Room floor because David and Dan
didn't even bother with the notion of
gray worm teleporting to the entrance of
the red keep when Jon was walking there
the whole time then I'm sure the death
of Daenerys would have been enjoyable at
this point but the audience is so
emotionally detached from the insane
roller coaster of dreadful writing that
the scene comes across as soulless oh
hey drogon are you here to give Jon some
consequences for killing your mother oh
you're not well okay then this leads
into what I'd consider the worst scene
in the show which is the election of the
new king everyone knows what's wrong
here but it's so hilarious to me that
Dave and Dan try to pass off stories
making a good King as if it's some kind
of big and smart Revelation when it just
comes across as absurdly stupid then
somehow Dave and Adan keep face planting
with the writing in regards to the iron
Islands not wanting Independence gray
worm allowing Tyrion to give a monologue
bran actually wanting it this including
the now sadly normal flare of sitcom
comedy and an incomprehensibly worse
method of electing a king do you realize
how much more corrupt this process will
be if it's an election process between
the elites you will have to deal with
intimidation bribery and flat out
assassination attempts in order to gain
votes to become king this system is so
much worse to the point that it's
disrespectful to dany's memory even
though she wanted to break the Wheel by
essentially making an even bigger wheel
I guess so I don't know the Iron Throne
is an excruciating ending to season 8
and now they want to continue the story
from here with Jon I wish the best of
luck to those writers because you have a
colossal obstacle ahead of you those are
my top 10 worst episodes of Game of
Thrones I hope you enjoyed going down
this curse and appalling Memory Lane of
sorts but yeah thank you for watching
and let me know what your top 10 worst
episodes are
foreign